good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's
question Tuesday sorry about the weird
lighting we're in like the back of a
movie theater in Berlin nothing creepy
about that I'm here with that wolf who
plays a cue in the Paper Towns movie a
peg Alice up with me Cara Delevingne who
plays Margo Roth Spiegelman in the movie
Paper Towns that's me
hi Cara how's it going call me Margo Oh
do you prefer to be called Margo please
how's it goin Margo pretty good alright
uh the first questions you're creating
me you're welcome it's my distinct
pleasure if you were an animal what
animal would you be
elephant who has inspired you the most
in your career John Green I bet you $2
you can't say bubbles angrily bubbles
bubbles bubbles bubbles bubbles bubbles
I bet you $2 you can't say bubbles as if
you are saying the last words to someone
you're about to execute bubbles can you
guys do an eye brows dance off and go
you're winning you're definitely you are
whoa I cannot analytic oh no no how do
you have so many muscles inside your
head you could be in the Olympics for
that I have wow they're congratulations
mm-hmm
you know uh the band Hamm is actually on
the soundtrack of Paper Towns
yeah no they're called hem hi and then
if they were gonna spit up and then one
of them started it as a solo career
she'd be called Haim solo can you give
me your impersonation of Gollum from
Lord of the Rings oh gollu top man have
you seen one of the Rings not recently
can you give me your impression of The
Godfather I'm gonna make you an offer
you can't refuse
I'm gonna give you the phone all stars
on Paper Towns and you're gonna have to
pick one you have to throw one in the
garbage would you write a llama if you
were given the chance
no would you write Obama if given the
chance obviously I want to see how hard
a llama actually spits you know cuz they
hold that spit on them then let's go
back on the mm-hmm mm-hmm
I want to see that mm mm are you
punching that hmm do you have any advice
on getting over a breakup be distracted
get a new one
there's plenty of them can you remember
your last dream
killed you on my dream did you kill me
what I wanted to say did you really so
guilty let me ask you a question right
back where you shot me in the back of
the head did you say bubbles I did would
you rather be a unicorn or a
hippopotamus again just to happen bottom
hip and and bottom is with the horn the
hippopotamus escaped a zoo today into my
mouth
no no cuts it happens they went
somewhere else just away from the zoo
because I know like adjusted everybody
who's with a giant horn on its face on
it so like a rhinoceros essentially then
no because every one of us out those
round teeth and also I would like the
the horns to go all the way down its
back alright I bet somebody can draw
that for you anything else that you'd
like it to be um I would like it to be
on a treadmill in the Andes um but it's
Cloudy with a hint of rain so there's a
rainbow with a leprechaun sliding down
the other end of the rivers family and
friends always him and then a puddle of
ladybirds
at the bottom of the treadmill waiting
to be taken up by an alien spaceship
let's see who can spell their last names
backwards the fastest n FML o w are
damaged which Hogwarts house are you in
I can answer this for you well what do
you think I'm a you're a ravenclaw it's
not even difficult cars that it was true
and she actually went to Hogwarts who
would win in an arm-wrestling contest
between NAT Wolff
and John Green all right I'll do it car
we videotape it three two one oh wow you
are strong uh I had no chance genuinely
hurt oh wow
heck I'll see you on Friday and lucky
sorry I love you then men